with many of us shuttered inside our
homes we're using social media and other
online information sources more than
ever but amid this viral pandemic the
spread of misinformation that's been
dogging our politics could now be a
matter of life or death
wired editor-in-chief Nick Thompson has
been writing about the role of
Technology in this current crisis he
joins us now to talk about it on nikka
morning I want to talk about the wired
piece on ibuprofen and the panic that
started to take us back I mean there's
always been panics about misinformation
and information snowballing but it's
magnified in this day and age
yeah it's magnified because we're so
worried and we're so looking for
anything that will help any sign of a
cure or anything we can tweet about so
we're absolutely primed and activated
from this information the ibuprofen
story is fascinating because there's a
medical research group puts out some
information about the way a specific
enzyme might interact with Kove at 19:00
and then perhaps there's another doctor
who says well maybe there's a connection
between ibuprofen and this enzyme so you
have to sort of thoughts but no studies
and then a French minister tweets be
worried about ibuprofen and Cove at 19
and suddenly it spreads around the world
so there's no mal intention there's no
one trying to do harm but as a result
people panic about ibuprofen so they go
to CVS which is dangerous in and of
itself and they start buying lots of
acetaminophen which has its own
potential concerns so a hazard is
created totally unintentionally but just
because of the speed at which
misinformation can spread so along those
lines and when you say there was no bad
intent but what do social media
platforms do right now to try to combat
this type of spread of misinformation
you know I've actually been pretty
impressed with the social media
platforms I've been quite critical of
them over the last few years as you know
they've all stepped up Silicon Valley
was quite early to see the magnitude of
this crisis so they all have worked hard
to adjust their algorithms to help find
misinformation and then very importantly
they've been doing some pro
positive things if you go to google.com
it tells you to do the five Instagram
has run stories about staying at home
YouTube is putting up videos that have
real coronavirus news so each of the
platforms is doing something positive my
favorite is probably whatsapp you can
text a number to the World Health
Organization and will send you back all
kinds of great information so they're
getting two things they're trying to
combat misinformation which is always
hard and lots gets through and they're
trying to proactively provide positive
useful information you mentioned a lot
of platforms you mentioned a lot of
platforms there Nick but so much of this
as you know at Wired at CBS News
everywhere else is still being driven by
Facebook yeah right Facebook is surely
the place we're going to the most right
now we can't connect with our friends in
real life so we're starting to use
Facebook more traffic on Facebook is
going up at Wired we've seen an
Eightfold increase at least sometimes a
40 fold increase and the number people
coming from Facebook to more stories so
Facebook is working hard to block the
misinformation provide some positive
information and to keep their servers
right and also knowing that bad stuff
does spread on that platform because of
the nature of the way it was set up hey
really quickly Nicola before you go a
lot of people are frustrated by
throttled Wi-Fi networks and and as it's
lower speeds with everyone online is
that gonna get better yeah it's not
gonna get better I think that the United
States is going to be okay I think that
the major tech companies the companies
that provide the information that slows
everything down namely Netflix and
YouTube will take steps that they did in
Europe to send out lower bandwidth
videos if there are real situations and
also I think what's generally happening
it is it's not a national bandwidth
problem in some places it's your wife
and you and your kids are using the same
Wi-Fi connections yeah everybody at home
that's the problem Nick Thompson thank
you very much but staying at home